et pour revenir justement sur ce jour
historique nous accueillons paul
thompson vice-président du parti des
conservateurs à paris bonjour monsieur
toujours merci d'être avec nous alors
après trois ans et demi de tractations
ça y est le royaume uni est sorti un de
l'union européenne quel est le sentiment
ce matin chez le britannique
certainement partagé hier soir il y a eu
des fêtes sur parme squad pour les des
propres excitant necas il ya eu un
vigile avec des bougies pour exprimer de
la tristesse et l'idée que les casses
selon ces participants voudraient
revenir dans le giron de l'union
européenne à boris nemtsov transmis aux
messages sur les médias sociaux qui
résume très bien la situation je pense
il a dit il ya ceux qui se sont ravis ce
qu'ils sont tristes et anxieux et ceux
qui sont surtout soulagée de sortir de
ces trois ans et demi de bagarre
interminables et la essentielle
aujourd'hui elle que le pays soit
unifiée et à aller de l'avant il à
dessein ma tâche en tant que premier
ministre deux oeuvres est en ce sens oui
c'est vrai que le discours de boris
johnson il est trés unificateur boris
johnson qui indique ce n'était pas la
fin mais le début
voilà le commencement de quelque chose
de nouveau en tout cas comment est-ce
que vous conservateur de france vous
avez vécu ce moment est bien la grande
majorité de notre
association pour vous avez une
association à paris n'était pas pour le
braque site est néanmoins la majorité de
cette majorité si je puis dire
on finit par estimé qu'il était
nécessaire de respecter le résultat du
référendum et d'aller de l'avant
certains certains n'ont jamais pu se
réconcilier avec le résultat parce que
ils se sont très pro-européens je
voudrais ajouter cependant que parmi les
propres excite et c'est le cas de boris
johnson
il ne s'agit pas du tout d'une sentiment
négatif envers les pays européens les
peuples européens aient les leaders
politiques européens absolument pas le
cas du sujet pour le brésil c'est une
certaine idée de la souveraineté n'est
pas du tout certain nationalisme
agressif et voyons les autres
négativement ça n'a jamais été le cas et
ce n'est pas la course ne sera pas la
kavo demain non plus mais je les parages
à lui déclaré nous aimons l'europe mais
nous on noie y sont d'union européenne
c'est justement ça le prend de terre
mayer était
déplacer je pense mais oui c'est le même
sentiment général dans l'esprit des
critiques de l'union européenne c'est un
une structure trop technocratique qui
éloigne a le pouvoir décisionnel des des
citoyens parce que la commission ne peut
pas être viré ou there on parle des
électeurs par exemple c'est toute cette
problématique là qui est au coeur de ce
genre de critiques
on entre maintenant dans une période de
transition qui va durer jusqu'au 31
décembre
donc concrètement rien ne change
aujourd'hui ça va se faire en douceur
mais il ya des gens qui sont dès
maintenant inquiet à l'image des des
irlandais certains aussi français qui
vivent royaume uni et vice versa ils
craignent justement la fin de cette
période de transition
vous comprenez leur crainte oui parce
que oui je les comprends parce que la
situation va changer de manière
significative à la fin de la période de
transition notamment en ce qui concerne
le régime d'immigration là il y aura de
grands changements le gouvernement a
annoncé la création d'un nouveau régime
de type australien ça veut dire ce titre
régime existe au canada aussi dans
d'autres pays où il y à un système de
points donc il ne s'agit pas du tout de
refuser l'immigration aux contrastes
sont d'origine pro-immigration on pourra
dire mais qui néanmoins vise très
franchement et en l'assumant une
sélectivité ou en fonction des besoins
du pays et donc pour les citoyens
français allemand et cetera qui
jusqu'ici ont un droit absolu
enfin presque absolu de de vivre de
travailler dans les dents au royaume uni
ça ce serait un changement radical
dernière question on a vu un léger
réveil les britanniques qui sont mitigés
on se rappelle de ces référendums
c'était 52% donc il ya une autre partie
des britanniques qui ne souhaitait pas
sortir de l'union européenne les
dirigeants changent est ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'un jour dans le futur avec
une nouvelle donne politique que le
royaume uni demandent de nouveau intégré
l'union européenne ce ne serait pas pour
tout de suite ce concevable si ce n'est
pas très probable je dirais mais
concevable jeu j'ai apporté ce jaune à
des chronos parce que la couverture est
très bien fait vers l'inconnu a mais ils
montrent une certaine dignité même une
certaine allure si je puis dire tout en
soulignant tous les inconnus et je le
cite pour répondre à votre question
parce que d'une je peux imaginer le
scénario ou le royaume-uni profite
vraiment de cette nouvelle liberté pour
devenir plus dynamique encore je pense
que c'est clairement affirmée de la part
des autorités américaines qu'ils veulent
renforcer à la relation avec le royaume
uni et il est possible qu'il ya certains
que l'anglosphère soit redynamisé je
pense que ce sera le cas et donc sa
tendance en monneret laura muni loin de
l'europe d'une autre côté si l'union
européenne devient plus efficace plus
fort plus rien on est temps vers
l'autonomie stratégique annuel elle
mènera macron appelle de ses voeux ne
pourrait aussi imaginer que le royaume
uni se disent mais finalement on devrait
se raccrocher à nouveau à autre un
europe 1 je pense que les deux sont
possibles très bien tout cas merci
beaucoup monsieur paul thompson
vice-président du parti des
conservateurs à paris d'avoir accepter
l'autre merci votre invitation